but in shorter terms Jin are a group of
beings in Middle Eastern and Islamic
lore that can take on many different
forms and shapes they appear in the
Quran and so have been established as an
important component of the Islamic
religion even though they may have been
interpreted in different ways in the
Quran it says quote and he created Jin
from smokeless
fire thus Jin are a type of being that
exist in the world created from
smokeless fire and that is distinct from
humans who were created from clay and
Angels created from light Jin are
conceived as creatures mostly invisible
to human senses but they can sometimes
become perceivable and even interact
with us in different ways often